rallye ce soir nous sommes en bretagne
tout comme pour marcel il ya deux mois
cette opération se déroulera en trois
temps d'abord ce journal de 20 heures
puis de meurthe et 2010 et à 18h30 c'est
la vie trois occasions pour nous de
découvrir la bretagne la bretagne de
toujours bien sûr mais aussi celle de
demain et vous verrez qu'au travers de
nos reportages la bretagne cette
péninsule armoricaine invente trouve
chaque jour des solutions pour s'adapter
à un monde qui a été souvent cruel à son
égard pour la plupart des français qui
suivent est en effet régulièrement les
comptes-rendus d'actualité la bretagne
c'est d'abord plogoff et la marée noire
nous verrons au travers de toutes ces
enquêtes que c'est cela bien sûr mais
c'est aussi beaucoup d'autres choses
parlons d'abord de la marée noire parce
que nous sommes ici à trégastel
trégastel seule localité à avoir été
touchés trois fois par la marée noire en
67 avec le coup de torrey canyon en 78
avec l'amour vocalises et puis donc le
plus récemment en 80 avec le tagnon
l'endroit où nous nous trouvons est en
soi un symbole car c'est là que furent
entreposer les déchets mazoutés de
l'amoco cadiz en soixante dix huit pour
toutes les côtes du nord et c'est là que
la municipalité va dans quelques jours
inaugurer un stade et un complexe
sportif construit sur ces déchets une
manière donc de se venger contre le sort
venu du large contre le sort et ceux qui
en assurent la responsabilité genre là
dufour marée noire une expression
inventée en mars 1967 lorsque ce bateau
le torrey canyon se brise sur un récif
entre la cornouaille et les îles saint
lin
c'est le début d'une longue liste de
naufrage qui vont polluer les plages
bretonnes
ainsi après le torrey canyon et ses cent
mille tonnes de mazout
c'est l'olympique bravery qui déverse sa
mini marée noire un millier de tonnes
seulement pourrait-on dire sur les côtes
de s en vient ensuite le bollène échoué
au large de l'île de sein dix mille
tonnes de pétrole brut déversés en mer
est particulièrement difficile à traiter
et puis il ya un peu plus d'un an c'est
au tour de l'amoco cadiz x 7 x 2 123
mille tonnes d'hydrocarbures vont aller
s'étaler sur 350 kilomètres de plat
et ce n'est pas fini puisqu'il faut
citer pour conclure cette liste le
bételgeuse le gino et ses 30000 tonnes
de pétrole qu'on ne retrouve plus et
enfin le tanio qui renferme encore dix
mille tonnes de pétrole par 87 mètres de
fond au large de l'île de batz une série
noire qui a bien évidemment marqué les
bretons ironie du sort le symbole du
drapeau breton représente une hermine
blanche sous laquelle on peut lire cette
phrase plutôt mourir que ceux sous ces
images désormais classique illustre un
combat difficile contre les carences au
niveau de la protection qui s'organise
au fil des ans les négligences des
équipages embarqués sur des bateaux
battant pavillon de complaisance et la
position géographique de la bretagne
devant laquelle passent tous les jours
des milliers de bateau en direction du
havre
oui toutes ces agressions ont été
ressenties très profondément parler
breton parce que ce n'était pas
seulement leur pelage quitté souliers
mais un petit peu aussi leur âme
aujourd'hui la colère est retombée il a
fallu s'activer pour préparer à la
saison que ces images de claude bellec
derrière moi témoigne je crois du fait
que les plages sont propres pour la
plupart d'entre elles nous n'avons pas
voulu nous satisfaire des bulletins
officiels des communiqués de victoire
là vous vous de vente et enquêter tout
au long de ces plages donc souillé par
le can you et je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui les bretons attendent les
touristes de pied ferme il reste encore
c'est vrai quelques plages au sable un
petit peu gras et surtout quelques
rochers où il ne fait pas bon
s'aventurer
mais d'une manière générale l'ensemble
est plus que satisfaisant même s'il a
fallu pour cela utiliser des détergents
tout au long de ce journal nous allons
essayer de parler donc de cette bretagne
qu'il faut aider en ce moment nous
parlons de ses multiples aspects de ces
handicaps de ses potentialités aussi et
nous le ferons avec d'autant plus de
passion que la plupart des journalistes
et des techniciens qui ont réalisé avec
daniel estève
ces reportages sont tous breton de coeur
ou de coeur mais d'abord l'actualité du
monde à commencer par les suites du
sommet de venise le roi hussein de
jordanie vient d'arriver à washington et
le roi khaled d'arabie à bonn mais les
regards seront surtout tournés vers
jérusalem où après deux jours d'attenté
en effet la position officielle des
israéliens vient de tomber c'est une
condamnation très vives du conseil des
neuf à venise venise c'est munich a dit
en substance mais la nba numen rencontre
au stade des documents rossini tu es
munich se rendent chaque génération
toutes les six domaines du côté de l'ol
paie de la série ce n'est pas non plus
le franc enthousiasme damas et le lte et
reproche aux européens de ne pas
affirmer le droit aux palestiniens à un
état indépendant
enfin la pravda qualifie est la
déclaration des 9,2 complaisante à
l'égard du processus de camp david
deuxième coup de projecteur sur le monde
d'aujourd'hui pretoria la capitale sud
africaine c'était aujourd'hui le
quatrième anniversaire des émeutes de
soweto tout près de johannesbourg à
nouveau des incidents un policier blanc
poignardé est un jeune africain blessés
toute la journée la grève générale a été
massivement suivi jean pierre points si
l'incident le plus grave a eu lieu près
d'une église catholique où devait se
tenir un meeting commémorant le drame
d'il ya quatre ans depuis deux jours
d'ailleurs et malgré l'interdît
gouvernementales des milliers de noirs
défilent dans le grand faubourg de
younes lourdes où se multiplient les
accrochages avec les forces de l'ordre
au cap également la grève a été très
suivie
toutes les écoles tous les magasins
fréquentés par des africains sont
demeurés fermés les émeutes de soweto en
juin 76 avaient fait près de 700 morts
un bilan qui a ému l'opinion mondiale
elle avait notamment entraîné le départ
l'étranger de nombreux jeunes noirs qui
avaient alors rejoint les camps
d'entraînement à la guérilla mouvement
de libération lines
l'actualité en france maintenant avec
tout d'abord c'est de dépêches sociale
qui viennent de tomber
tout d'abord les chiffres du chômage qui
se sont accrus même très nettement en
mai un million quatre cent soixante
douze mille cinq cents demandeurs
d'emploi donc pour le mois de mai c'est
énorme c'est en tout cas une grosse
augmentation par rapport à avril puis 2
3% en données corrigées +6 2% en données
brutes et puis une deuxième information
toute récente la décision par la cgt et
la cfdt d'organiser en commun mercredi
25 juin une journée nationale d'action
pour les bas salaires et la réduction du
temps de travail et demain comme s'ouvre
à bordeaux le congrès de force ouvrière
on verra bien quelle sera l'attitude de
cette centrale
le roi de suède à paris depuis la fin de
la matinée car ou star a déjà eu un
premier entretien avec le chef de l'état
entretien suivi d'un déjeuner privé
le couple royal doit passer deux jours à
paris avant de se rendre à pau c'est à
dire dans la patrie du maréchal
bernadotte qui fut le fondateur de la
dynastie dont tahar gusta est l'héritier
le souverain suédois a visité l'institut
pasteur et le roi et la reine iront ce
soir au château de versailles pour une
grande soirée de gala une lettre
manuscrite de recevoir merci mans de
jean paul ii au président de la
république
dieu fasse dit le saint père que ma
visite soit profitable au peuple
français qui a manifesté tant d'intérêt
pour l'événement et en attachement au
successeur de pierre politique
suite des débats aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée autour du projet perfide
sécurité et liberté la motion de renvoi
proposé par le groupe communiste a été
repoussée alain peyrefitte a répété une
nouvelle fois que son texte n'était pas
répressif puisque nous parlons de
liberté sachez que le parti républicain
pour lancer la fête du bourget your gun
prochain la fête qui porte le même nom a
présenté aujourd'hui le livre de son
secrétaire général
jacques blanc une politique pour les
libertés économie pilule amère pour les
parisiens avec l'augmentation des tarifs
de
ratp et de la sncf banlieue augmentation
que l'état y maintenant pour nous pierre
marziali la hausse de la ratp était
attendu son ampleur est tout de même une
mauvaise surprise +10 7% sur le ticket
de métro qui passera le 1er juillet à 1
franc 75 et de francs 70 en première
quant à la carte orange elle va
augmenter de 21% de 85 à 2 113 francs
selon le nombre de sources ces hausses
interviennent presque en même temps que
celle qui frappe les automobilistes
puisque depuis 48 heures tous les
carburants ont augmenté de 3 centimes
par litre
rappelons que la même semaine la hausse
des péages d'autoroute variable selon
les secteurs s'élevait en moyenne à huit
et demi pourcent quant à la sncf elle
avait pris les devants en mars dernier
avec 9 4% de hausse sur les tarifs
voyageurs auraient déjà les centrales
syndicales protestent contre ces os du
côté du cnpf un bilan plutôt pessimiste
pour le mois de juin le ralentissement
de l'activité française et du genre mais
amorcé annonce donc la centrale
patronale
autre bilan celui de l' agence des
économies d'énergie pour son directeur
jean poulit tu la consommation de 80 ne
dépassera pas celle de 79 lagence veut
désormais s'appuyer davantage sur les
élus locaux et développer la
récupération d énergie perdue
c'est ce que fait depuis longtemps une
ville mais ce dont l'objectif est de
gagner ce 22% par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est à dire 3 millions de
francs donc en économies d'énergie
le reportage de jean p cieux
ce n'est pas de l'essence que je mets
dans cette voiture mais du gaz de
pétrole liquide metz où je me trouve
actuellement est une des premières
villes de france à utiliser ce carburant
pour ses véhicules municipaux
on en a transformé une dizaine auto
fourgonnette camionnette en y installant
ce réservoir en réservoir de ce type
ici par exemple dans cette 4l il fait 50
6 litres et il permet à cette voiture
une autonomie de l'ordre de 500 km la
transformation elle-même coûte à peu
près 4000 francs et est amorti en
environ quatre ans outre qu'il ne pollue
pas l'atmosphère l'avantagent du gaz et
son prix 2 francs le litre c'est à dire
40 % moins cher que l'essence
si l'expérience est concluante mais ce
compte transformer dès l'an prochain
sans véhicules municipaux économie 1000
francs par véhicule
chaque année les responsables de la
ville font aussi porter leurs efforts
sur le trafic plan de circulation mille
litres de moins chaque année par voiture
parking près du centre et transports
publics avec des minibus à 50 centimes
la place mais ce sont les bâtiments qui
fourniront les plus fortes économies
1800 tonnes d'équivalent pétrole par an
près de deux millions de francs
isolation d'abord on a commencé l'an
dernier par les écoles on prévoit aussi
la régulation de toutes les chaudières
140 immeubles sont concernés la ville
touchera certes une prime de lagence
pour les économies d'énergie un million
mais elle dépensera bien plus 6 millions
cette année le dixième de ses
investissements sans doute le record de
france croit qu'il est de saine gestion
de faire un certain nombre d'efforts et
on peut les faires calfeutrer les écoles
remplacer les ampoules incandescentes
par la lumière froide économiser sur les
voitures revoir les contrats de
chauffage devrait nous amener 2500
tonnes équivalent pétrole a économisées
par an ce qui incontestablement serait
un gain pour le budget municipal mais
aussi une action civique indispensable
actuellement les économies attendues 22%
viendront s'ajouter à celle que metz
fait déjà depuis 10 ans grâce surtout
aux ordures ménagères qui fournissent l
usine municipale chauffage électricité
le quart de son énergie comme quoi les
économies d'énergie ici c'est vraiment
une habitude l'informatisation du
fichier des comptes bancaires depuis ce
matin elle est totale c'est ainsi que
désormais chaque ouverture de compte
sera communiquée au fisc aux douanes
automatiquement c'est valable pour tous
les établissements bancaires financiers
aussi les caisses d'epargne
manifestation d'agriculteurs en deux
points du territoire à perpignan et à
marseille à perpignan vous voyez les
paysans ont incendié six camions de
primeurs en provenance d'espagne ont
détruit trois autres par explosif ce
matin sur l'autoroute a9 entre perpignan
le boulou c'est à dire environ 15
kilomètres de la frontière espagnole
et puis à marseille ce sont des tonnes
de tomates qui ont été déversées comme
vous le voyez dans les rues 45 tonnes de
tomates
en tout ce qui fait que les marseillais
ont fait leur marché donc pendant que
les agriculteurs manifestaient leur
colère justice aujourd'hui à belfort
début du procès intenté par la cfdt au
pc le sommet de la section locale
communiste avec notamment accusés
allemands maire d'avoir pacifié
l'algérie olemps l'âme sport borg tête
de série numéro 1 pour wimbledon ce par
au moins une surprise en revanche le
classement de yannick noah va ravir ses
supporters le français est en effet
numéro 12 têtes de série numéro 12 avant
même amaya clair ou feedback et puis le
point sur la transat le dernier
classement donne la main qu'un fils weld
devant riguidel et kersauson mais il
reste une incertitude sur marc pajot
dont la balise ne répond plus mais il
s'agit sans doute d'une panne le point
avec gilles cozanet la transat entre
dans sa deuxième semaine de course et
les concurrents qui jusque là avec ou
connu des conditions métérologiques très
clémente
sont entrés dans des tempêtes qui
malmènent hommes et bateaux l'atlantique
nord retrouve ainsi son vrai visage
pour le moment donc ses fils wild qui
est en tête devant eugène riguidel et
olivier de kersauson
weld le doyen de la course il a 66 ans
sur la route sud à 246 km d'avant sur
eugène riguidel qui semble avoir perdu
toutes ses chances après les incidents
qui ont affecté son trimaran olivier de
kersauson à 289 km de retard et plonge
vers le sud pour trouver des conditions
climatiques plus clémentes
quant à marc pajot dont la balise argos
ne semble plus fonctionner il est plus
loin dans le classement mais dans la
réalité pourrait être devant tout le
monde
la panne de balises dont il est victime
affecte d'ailleurs une vingtaine
d'autres concurrents une panne due à un
défaut d'étanchéité des balises
parmi les nombreux concurrents qui font
demi tour
il y en a eu beaucoup en une semaine il
faut maintenant signalé jean yves
terlain qui fait route vers la rochelle
il a cassé ses deux enrouleur de phoque
et ne dispose donc plus que de sa grand
voile
enfin un dernier volet de l'actualité
sportive lendemains de fête au mans chez
l'écurie française renault vous
connaissez peut-être mal l'homme qui a
vaincu les porsche au mans il était
l'invité d'antenne de midi c'est jean
rondeau et vous allez comprendre que
cette victoire est celle de la passion
mais aussi d'une équipe toute entière
nous écoutons jean rondeau d'antenne dès
midi tout à l'heure que huit salariés
qui sont mécaniciens techniciens et qui
me suivent toute l'année je neuvième
personne qui s'appelle marjorie boss qui
recherche qui a la lourde charge de
rechercher des financements et qui
heureusement pour nous les ai trouvés
grâce à un travail énorme qu'elle
qu'elle produit le jour de la course
nous étions 60 personnes à peu près pour
toute cette organisation pour toute
cette opération
vous avez gagné le mans est ce que vous
allez maintenant concevoir des voitures
pour les ventes dans le commerce
non c'est pas du tout mon objectif je
n'ai absolument aucune ambition
commercial je ne sente pas être pris
dans des contraintes commerciales trop
haut trop lourde
tout au plus je sauterai fournir de
certaines de mes voitures à deux bons
pilotes capables de gagner des courses
et donc au maximum on verrait 7 juillet
rondot au départ des 24 heures du mont
des serpents pour moi un maximum de
l'année prochaine c'est probable voilà
avant de revenir à la partie bretonne de
nos informations je vais vous rappeler
que ce soir question de temps vous donne
rendez vous avec un débat que vous
présenterons louis blériot et betty
dureau sur la défense nationale face au
danger nucléaire
sommes nous prêts nos équipes de
reportage et trois débats essaieront
nous apporter des réponses donc de quoi
parle t-on en bretagne aujourd'hui si
bien la marée noire bien sûr que nous
avons évoqué au départ le plot goff
aussi vous savez que pour l'instant la
procédure suit son cours mais
l'hostilité des habitants de la pointe
du raz n'a pas désarmé
on en a parlé encore hier à brest au
cours de la fête de l'udb c'est de dire
l'union démocratique bretonne
c'est un mouvement qui se situe
résolument dans la mouvance de la gauche
aux côtés du pc du ps et les radicaux de
gauche mais à sa place très distinctes
objective des contacts que l'udb est en
train de prendre en ce moment avec les
occitans et les corses la présentation
d'un candidat commun aux prochaines
présidentielles il y avait hier à brest
près de 25000 personnes pour faire la
fête en écoutant notamment pierre perret
gilles servat et autres chanteurs pas
seulement breton l'actualité sociale ici
c'est par exemple le conflit de
politesse à lannion c'est aussi la
poursuite de la grève au joint français
à saint brieuc une partie du personnel a
repris le travail mais aujourd'hui une
assemblée générale a décidé de
poursuivre la lutte chez les grévistes
et puis notre manière à nous de parler
de l'actualité sociale en bretagne c'est
de vous présenter une femme près
étonnante ouvrier a précisément à saint
brieuc mais à l'usiné chaffoteaux l est
délégués du personnel s'appelle dorothée
letessier elle a 26 ans un enfant et en
attend un second
elle vient d'écrire un livre qui fait
déjà beaucoup parler s'appelle le voyage
à paimpol c'est le récit d'une fugue
un jour elle en a eu assez de tout son
travail du syndicat de son foyer et tout
ce talent l'a raconté dans son livre et
une seconde fois à patricia cost
oh
je me disais qu'un jour il y aurait un
couple voire une famille qui me
cacherais la forêt j'essayais me
persuader qu'on pouvait vivre autrement
et voilà que je fais quarante kilomètres
pour prendre un bain tranquillement je
n'ai rien à faire c'est louche et
délicieux je suis assise et c'est déjà
beaucoup de plaisir aux pièces devant
une machine
même s'il y un siège de bouygues faire
pour s'asseoir on est crispé
ce soir alizée ou à la maison elle n'a
que des gestes conditionnée par la
fonction qu'elle doit qu'elle pourra
voir qu'elle doit assumer auxquelles
réagit contre ça en
en désirant la solitude pour pouvoir
s'exprimer comme elle veut jean
on se sent toujours un peu infirme et
quelquefois c'est plutôt qu'en mode on
cache sous le nom mal au dos toute
l'amertume accumulé non c'est pire que
le bind c'est quelque chose pour
laquelle on n'a pas ou n'a pas commis de
faute au départ dans lequel on est
condamnés quand même j'ai voir béatrice
on se dit si tu veux pas 35 faudrait
être à ma place pour comprendre mais on
sait qu'on se comprend malgré tout on
devine la fin du mois sur la corde raide
à la mise en plis avachi et maintenant
11 au boulot signe à la scène de ménage
on se fait pas de cadeau mais on s'aime
bien aller m'installer là vous faites de
graisse on peut pas bluffer on est tel
qu'on est
on est celle qui fait ce type de boulot
là qui a telle latitude par rapport aux
chèvres et bon ça
on est un peu nu voix par rapport aux
autres je me suis reconnue aussi dense
et j'ai pas été la seule de toute façon
je pense qu'on a été beaucoup à le
penser et personne n'ose et l'exprimé on
a trouvé quelqu'un parmi nous qui a osé
le faire
c'est pas un peu exagéré non c'est pas
exagérer c'est vrai qu'on garde un
produit de presque toutes les 5 minutes
puis mais ce qu'on se résigne pas enfin
deux fois plus ou moins on obligé par
l'escalier de faire je monte sur
l'appétit qui surplombe l'aller à 4
mètres au dessous de moi 12 13 500
ouvriers se massent en chahutant elle
peut on se laisse aller à croire que
tout va changer mais je n'arrive pas
incarner cette image de télé québec
comme il faut centre plus faire des
délégations inutile à la préfecture
lénine avec sa cravate et son
attaché-case énerve à côté de moi il va
parler
non il ya une rage de dents je raconte
des choses qui existent dans la vie
syndicale dans la vie ouvrière et ajouts
à voir pourquoi il y en aurait pas tabou
et d'autres non l'avis de lusine voyage
de mme à discuter on va pas discuter
je dis ce que je souhaite dans un
caisson de marty bon alors peut-être que
sont bonnes et mauvaises en a rien été
complètement à plat et et qu'elle aime
se défouler gallas en tout cas on va
très bien mais vic c'est dommage qu'il
n'y ait pas de perspective les repas
s'en est pris à un moment pour les
perspectives de ne pas trop grave ont
fait usage pour lui de donner un
programme de vous
situation dorothée en fait n'a jamais
été à paimpol elle n'a quitté ni sa
maison ni son mari ouvrier comme el nil
usine elle a tout simplement fait un
roman mais pas comme les autres eh bien
nous sommes ici à quelques centaines de
mètres de l'endroit où nous étions au
tout début de ce journal c'est à dire à
pullman à ambert hausse directe l'entrée
du port de ploumanac'h l'endroit qui
sans doute a été le plus touché par la
dernière marée noire le tanio et comme
vous le voyez ces rochers maculées de
noir et bien il faut bien les regarder
car dans quelques jours il ne devrait
plus l'être ils sont en train d'être
vigoureusement attaqué par l'armée c'est
le dernier bastion qui résiste bien dans
le trégor
vous imaginez que tous les petits
pêcheurs de ploumanac'h hommes de tous
les porcs avoisinants ont eu beaucoup de
problèmes à cause de cette marée noire
ce n'est pas hélas ce ne sont pas là les
seuls problèmes qu'on rencontrait les
pêcheurs en bretagne depuis quelques
années vous allez le voir au travers de
ce reportage de deux bretons de la
rédaction en régaler et patrick derrien
un reportage tourné à lorient sur les
difficultés de la grande pêche
l'industrie de la pêche ne fixe pas le
prix du poisson elle le subit au hasard
des arrivages des ententes de la
spéculation les cours varient mais
presque toujours dans le sens ascendant
résultat 1 kilos de merlan payer 3
francs à l'armateur se retrouve à 25
francs chez votre poissonnier de 1973 à
1980 le prix du poisson payer au
chalutier a été multiplié par deux le
prix du fioul par six ce qui explique en
partie la crise que traverse et gros
unités spécialisées dans ce qu'on
appelle la pêche industrielle coût du
gasoil coup du déchargement aussi qui
intervient pour 18% dans le prix du kilo
de poisson
les bateaux actuellement fonctionne à
perte et les armateurs vendent leur
chalutier
oui je crois que le problème à lorient
et spécifiques dans la mesure où les
armements bons qu'ils ont des bateaux
sont essentiellement donc d un moment de
production le bateau produit le bateau
pêche du poisson mais lorsque le poisson
et mit donc sous criée et est vendue
sous criée le poisson n'est plus du tout
maîtrisée par le producteur c'est à dire
par l'armateur et par les marins et il
est certain donc au niveau des prix il y
a donc des proches des gros problème
actuellement est également au niveau de
l'écoulement de la production qui n'est
pas du tout maîtrisée par les armateurs
ce jour-là à lorient on importait 18
tonnes de filet de merlu surgelés en
provenance d'argentine
alors que quatre tonnes de merlu frais
pêché par des chalutiers du port ne
trouvait pas d'acheteur et prenez la
direction de l' usine d'aliments pour
bétail à 20 centimes le kilo
importations d'à côté destruction de
l'autre une manière d'agir
incompréhensible dans un pays qui
enregistre 3 milliards de déficit pour
le commerce extérieur des produits de la
mer
la plupart de ses navires au moins de 5
ans d'âge valeur 20 millions de francs
financés par l'aide publique
mais ces chalutiers industriels sont
déficitaires alors certains armateurs
ont eu l'idée des bases avancées les
bateaux économiseront le trajet
aller-retour en carburant soit 5 jours
déchargeront leurs poissons près des
zones de pêche quant aux équipages ils
seront relevés par avion nous avons bien
l'intention de ramener au maximum nos
élèves hamilton que notre groupe pêche
aujourd'hui ce qui représente quand même
plus de 30 à 35% du des captures du port
de lorient
je conçois bien que si cette capture
doivent du jour au lendemain
disparaissent du port de riorges
ça risque de poser des problèmes
économiques graves pas au niveau de la
production
parce que nos marins devront toujours
aller pêcher le poisson mais il risque
d'avoir certaines mutations dans tout ce
qui se passe en aval de notre production
le réveil sera certes difficile pour le
port de lorient car la pêche
industrielle représente 55 % des apports
mais en aval du bateau dockers mareyeurs
mandataire personne ne veut faire des
sacrifices
personne n'a semble-t-il conscience que
tout dépend du navire et qu' un emploi
en r procure quatre emplois à terre
d'ici la fin de l'année douze chalutiers
déposeront leurs poissons à kyle en
écosse
la seule solution trouvée pour garantir
l'outil de travail et l'emploi
mais la mère peut apporter d'autres
semences à l'économie bretonne
on recherche beaucoup du côté de bresse
duplex aux mais aussi ailleurs tout ce
qui peut apporter un sang neuf un petit
peu visite y en a sept économies par
exemple l'aquaculture c'est à dire la
culture traditionnelle des huîtres comme
ces parcs vous voyez derrière moi mais
aussi plus raffiné plus sophistiqués
comme on dit en langage moderne
aujourd'hui celle de l'élevage du saumon
et vous allez découvrir à travers ce
reportage de jean lou qu'elle me gêne de
jean vila commandes dans une
exploitation
on peut faire mettre tous à partir de
rien ou deux fois par jour joël laurent
et patrice morvan viennent d'ouvrir leur
élevage de poissons des truites de mer
ils sont aquaculteurs et avec six autres
copains ils ont monté il ya trois ans la
première coopérative à quoi sont
françaises
si atteint 10 dans la rade de brest pour
y arriver ils ont investi en moyenne
chacun cent mille francs aujourd'hui ils
produisent plus de 100 tonnes de truites
de mer par an soit près de la moitié de
la production française
pour l'instant on attend de
l'aquaculture qu'elle porte ses fruits
c'est à dire qu'elles nous permettent
d'atteindre des productions relativement
important du style de celles qui sont
atteintes en norvège soit danemark sont
en écosse dans un deuxième temps bien
sûr apporté sur le littoral l'emploi qui
fait cruellement défaut
compte tenu des problèmes que l'on
rencontre au niveau de la pêche surtout
en bretagne
aqua coop est l'émanation réel du qnexa
le centre national d'exploitation des
océans qui a une antenne le code le
centre océanologique de bretagne ici on
prépare l'aquaculture française de
demain on met au point entre autres
l'élevage du turbo du bar ou de la sole
la sole par exemple et économiquement
l'espèce la plus importante
la france en importent l'équivalent en
valeur de tout le poisson débarqué au
port de boulogne
il est très difficile d'être complète
donnez une peinture de ce que pourra
être la grippe il purgeait fax est
globalement que la voie en tout cas
comme une mise en valeur trappe à des
portions que son plus haut malgré
l'essai il fera une marque
ici près de tréguier dans les côtes du
nord la sodam la société pour le
développement de l'aquaculture de la
bretagne a commencé les premiers essais
d'élevage en milieu naturel
cette unité a pour vocation de prendre
le relais des travaux réalisés à brest
en laboratoire on y trouve des truites
de mer bien sûr mais aussi des saumons
et des turbos le rôle de la sodam
consiste aussi à faire la démonstration
de la rentabilité de l'aquaculture en
france que nous avons aussi été obligés
de rechercher les débouchés du produit
et 7,2 partie de la démonstration est
aussi importante sinon plus que la
partie technique puisque nous devons
avoir pour être rentable pour être
crédible un compte d'exploitation qui
sera en équilibre
est-ce que c'est rentable l'attractivité
la rentabilité elle reste encore à
démontrer ce que l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est quand on élève de la
truite en mer on ne perd pas d'argent et
le saumon alors le saumon il n'est pas
question de parler de rentabilité sur le
second qui a été choisie en france
l'aquaculture permettra-t-elle à des
pêcheurs français de se reconvertir
c'est le pari lancé par des chercheurs
est que des aquaculteurs bretons tentent
aujourd'hui de démontrer c'est donc l'un
des espoirs de la bretagne
d'autres espoirs que nous découvrirons
demain dans nos journaux de 12h45 et de
18h30 par exemple l'électronique encore
que l'électronique et susciter quelques
craintes
récemment ici nous sommes dans le temple
de l'électronique nous sommes à pleumeur
bodou à quelques centaines de mètres de
l'endroit où se trouve installé le
radôme et la station spatiale et
pourtant vous le voyez ici ce ne sont
que dolmen que menhirs et un petit peu
plus loin elle est couverte car la
bretagne c'est aussi cela et si les
quelque chose d'ancré encore plus
profondément dans la terre dans l'âme
bretonne c'est je crois le désir de
survivre et de garder une certaine
originalité la bretagne notamment de
ressusciter une langue qu'ils étaient en
train doucement de mourir c'est pour ça
qu'il me semble que l'initiative que
vous allez maintenant découvrir à
travers ce reportage d'alain doublé ce
qui est très intéressante elle est
signée d'une association qui s'appelle
diwan et qui a décidé de créer des
maternelles en breton en breton
précisément diwan
ça veut dire le germe
nous sommes dans l'une de ces écoles
diwan à cléder près de saint pol de léon
dans le finistère est parti à travers la
bretagne il ya douze écoles maternelles
en breton aucune n'a plus de 15 élèves
la première a été créée en mai 1977
écoles en breton seulement et non breton
français expliquent les responsables il
faut donner une chance supplémentaire
aux bretons le français en pratiquer en
famille qu'est ce qui pousse ces
familles justement à faire apprendre le
breton à leurs enfants
voici une motivation parmi d'autres et
s'est passé chez moi très conscience
quand j'étais jeune j'avais 18 ans je me
suis rendu compte que je savais de
langues
vous savez le français et le breton est
une de ces deux langues était une ample
foulée de partout seconde langue
personne ne voulait reconnaître et il ya
eu à partir de là un cheminement qui m'a
conduit actuellement à emmener les
enfants à l'école du mois c'est une
sorte de revanche alors n est ce pas
juste de la faire supporter par vos
enfants n'ont pas du tout pas du tout je
ne crois pas parce que c'est la langue
bretonne est une langue très riche et
certainement très enrichissant pour un
enfant d'être bilingue
ici à cléder la municipalité a fourni un
local au bord de la mer que souhaiter de
mieux pour les leçons de choses
bretonnants ou non bretonnants tous les
enfants sont acceptés gratuitement dans
les écoles diwan
elles forment une association sans but
lucratif qui vit de subventions charte
culturelle municipalité me particulier
jeudi salle de famille il ya meilleur
l'accalmie
sablé ou mademoiselle dans ce genre de
maternelle est ce que vous employez une
pédagogie un peu spécial
évidemment enfin on est si j'avais
l'impression de faire exactement la même
chose que dans les maternelles ordinaire
je ne serai pas là puisque on essaie de
s'intéresser surtout à ce qu'on a dans
la région des exemples concrets
ici on ramasse les algues on en fait des
tableaux en tout cas on va voir les
vieilles en prend leurs coiffes et on
utilise des mots tissier ce sens aux
martyrs et sur les efforts pour faire
des dessins graphiques pour
l'apprentissage à l'écriture
prépare-t-on un ghetto bretonnants ses
enfants ce n'est pas sûr on constate que
la plupart des élèves de diwan
proviennent de familles où l'on ne parle
pas le breton
il semble bien que du wan correspondent
à un besoin
oui ce reportage nous rappelle beaucoup
cette maxime que vous connaissez presque
tous maintenant qui datent du 19e et
encore du début du xxème siècle il est
interdit de cracher par terre et de
parler breton cette phrase en effet
beaucoup de lecteurs l'ont découvert il
y a cinq ans à peu près grâce à pierre
jakez hélias et à ce livre
le cheval d'orgueil et bien pour ceux
qui n'ont pas encore lu ce livre qui est
une sorte de bible ici encore qu'il
était contestée on se souvient du cheval
coucher de tellier graal
claude chabrol s'est proposé de tourner
et de restituer donc au cinéma ce que
vous allez voir dans à peu près trois
mois la rentrée le cheval d'orgueil
tournée en pays bigouden non pas ici à
trégunc dans cette superbe cathédrale au
milieu du pays du trégor mais en pays
bigouden c'est à dire pas très loin de
quimper et c'est là que
les reporters de faire trois sont allés
rejoindre il y a quelques jours tout
chabrol tournant le cheval d'orgueil ce
qui a été possible et là c'était de voir
un village entier comme je l'espérais au
village entier qui correspond à ce qu'il
était en 1911 en 1910 évidemment cce
tant mieux d'ailleurs c'est de ma faute
si alors ce qu'on a fait on a en a pris
plusieurs plusieurs coins différents et
il y aura un village fectivement ton a
fait d'ailleurs le
la topographie mais qui n'existe pas qui
sera là qu lancé l'assemblage de
plusieurs plusieurs endroits différents
a refait la moitié des gens qui jouent
dans le film ce sont des comédiens
professionnels je ne vais pas utiliser
des amateurs de rythmes et ses comédiens
professionnels j'ai essayé une ou deux
exceptions près de ne pas les prendre
trop célèbre pour pour que le décalage
de leur célébrité vérone qu'ils ont
interprété avant ne crée pas un problème
pour lui notifications etc avec le
refoulement
elle s'est tenue dans toute la force
vient de là de la vérité des détails
donc il suffit pour moins de respecter
cette vérité pour en tout cas avoir là
une grosse partie 2-2 du niveau 1 sur
l'écran on peut dire en gros qu'il va du
début du siècle à 1 au début de la
guerre de 40 ans deuxième guerre
mondiale
nous nous arrêtons la fin de la première
il ya eu là un moment de transformation
très importante parce que le bigouden
qui était très fermé sur lui même s'est
aperçu d'un seul coup qu il appartenait
à une une collectivité qui était qu'elle
jusqu'au haut rhin quoi et pour laquelle
est obligé de donner son sang est en
même temps les gens de
il fallait que la vie continue et ce
sont les femmes qui sont mis à s'occuper
des c'est très jeune garde absolument
qu'un droit je viens voir le tournage du
film est naturellement je suis là pour
tous les renseignements qu'il est
possible de demander mais ceci dit moi
je laisse les artistes faire exactement
ce qui leur plaît ce qu'ils ont dans la
tête
d'autre part je n'ai absolument aucun
goût pour la censure et bien nous
quittons maintenant le pays bigouden
pour retrouver le trégor et pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont des notions un
petit peu imprécise de géographie
signale que c'est dans la partie nord
des côtes du nord nous sommes dit très
précisément à dix kilomètres de
l'endroit où nous étions au tout début
de ce journal c'est délire trégastel
aujourd'hui nous sommes à trébeurden
trébeurden d'où vous retrouverez
d'ailleurs nos émissions demain de 18
heures 30 et de 12h45 c'est à dire donc
c'est la vie et antennes de midi ces
deux là qu'auront lieu les deux derniers
volets de cette émission spéciale
bretagne nous allons parler de la météo
très rapidement comme vous l'avez pu le
constater dans ce reportage et bien il y
ait une alternance de petites
d'éclaircies et de temps disons plus
désagréable c'est un temps assez bretons
encore qu'il ait fait très très beau ici
on met est en jeu nous nous quittons pas
comme ça car je crois que le mieux c'est
de se quitter en musique avec un
chanteur que vous connaissez assez peu
qu'il n'a pas produit le disque c'est
dommage d'ailleurs il s'appelle pierre
ménoret et il va nous quitter sur la
chanson de circonstance la bretagne
là où finit le theux
c'est un coin de grisolles
ils viennent vocale
écorchée par la pluie
un coin d'ombré de pierre
et le sang
talent que ce
embarrassé par la main
une tête de pur
à la pointe le monde on dirait un
faisceau
mon pays dans le vent
une odeur de légende un veau
le cadre à
je
salut
sur image du temps son histoire
peu dans des calmes
des clochers des châteaux
des cités englouties
un passé fait le croire
les ruines et les prieurs
des chances et des murmures
ap les installe j
les arguments aux paris la bruyère
il garde de ses regrets
mon pays dans le vent
du fond de son âme